c'est avec le temps
et de du renseignement que j'ai appris
ce que je sais de la quête de la
rédemption
j'étais un homme recherché dans la tête
était mise à prix
mais pour l'instant j'étais libre
un fugitif sans foyer uni pays
bombay c'était un endroit où tout le
monde prenait un nouveau départ
attention
heureusement que j'étais là vous êtes
peut-être mon ange gardien sûrement pas
il ya trop de choses diabolique en moi
pour ça
jamais la bombe et il ne lui dit rien on
a tous des secrets je te raconte le mien
si tu me racontes le tien
numéro de bombay merci mais non pourquoi
monsieur pour mais seulement après trois
noms c'est un pli nous
et c'est le quartier de st gallois dan
ma maison
ces droits ne marche pas sur chacun de
nous aide celui qui en a besoin
pourquoi voulez-vous et des sagas
l'ohada je sais ce que j'ai fait je dois
payer comme les erreurs
on doit tous essayé de compenser nous
tu ferais quand déjà intéressant pour un
homme qui va hériter les problèmes soit
je vous demande quelque chose que vous
acceptez de faire soit jamais le feu à
cet endroit
tout le monde cherche à fuir quelque
chose à bombay
ça ne marche pas crois moi
je me suis foutu dans un sacré merdier
je repartirai pas les mains vides
j'aurais dû te tirer quand on avait
l'occasion
[Musique]
tu peux qui verrait de tout mais pas toi
même
je crois que j'ai besoin de courir vers
un but au lieu de fuir
[Musique]